bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france avant de revenir sur
les sujets à l'ordre du jour de ce g20
revenons sur le contexte on vient
d'évoquer un certain nombre de discorde
entre paris et washington entre paris et
londres tension aussi toujours entre les
états unis et la chine est-ce que est
alors en quoi la pandémie at elle a
exacerbé les rivalités selon vous et
bien d'après du tout simplement là elle
a exacerbé les relations entre les les
pays mais également entre les genres
même puisque les flux économiques les
flux humains
circuler beaucoup moins bien ainsi n'ont
quasiment pas alors qu on a depuis deux
ans effectivement un ralentissement des
déplacements des dirigeantes et puis une
forme d'inertie
même si les diplomaties nationales
continuent leur travail mais c'est vrai
que c'est beaucoup moins facile pour les
chefs d'entreprise pour les économistes
font les chefs d'état que de gérer des
pays via des appels téléphoniques et des
réunions via skype ou d'autres types de
comment dire de
du communication visuelle et donc oui
effectivement la pandémie est un petit
peu responsables de ces refroidissement
puisque les gens ne se sont pas
rencontrés ou très peu souvent alors
espérons que cette fois ci les choses
vont redémarrer d'autant plus que les
enjeux sont maintenant très important
bien sûr qu'il ya des rivalités entre la
chine l'europe les états et me convient
nos amis anglais mais ce qu'il faut
faire maintenant c'est relancer la
machine économique mondiale et faire en
sorte que à la fois les investisseurs
reprennent confiance dans le système
économique que les chaînes
d'approvisionnement se cale bien et
qu'on fait à sur leur travail de
délivrance du produit voire de service
et puis aussi penser à toutes les
populations pour que continue la lutte
contre la pauvreté l'extrême pauvreté et
améliorer
je dirais l'ensemble du pouvoir d'achat
moyen du ensemble de la population de la
planète sans oublier les sujets sont
nombreux la paix dans le monde et puis
bien évidemment l'écologie et notre
planète terre le g20 s'ouvre demain à
rome en l'absence physique des
présidents russe et chinois quoi donc va
servir ce nouveau sommet alors la guider
au sommet il va te dire compte bien
évidemment des entretiens qu'auront eu
les diplomates
russes ou chinois car effectivement
c'est plus marquants lorsqu'un dirigeant
ses rangs en personne un sommet du g20
ceci dit
le travail est quand même fait et les
pays sont représentés
c'est dire qu'on fait quand un président
arrive ou s'il n'arrive pas il ya déjà
du travail qui est fait sur la table des
équipes qui sont concertés on a préparé
des projets et on arrive quand même à
des résultats c'est vrai qu'il faut
souhaiter que pour le prochain g20
l'ensemble des dirigeants de la planète
n'oublions pas que ses dirigeants sont
souvent accompagnés d'autres pays qui ne
sont pas nommés dans le g20 qui sont
concernés par la géopolitique par
l'économie parole l'environnement et qui
participe aussi est forte heureusement
de près ou de loin parce qu'ils n'ont
pas la voix je dirai au chapitre danser
grand sommeil pour elle également
représentant et est également représenté
un sommet qui doit donc préparer les
travaux de la coop 26 chaque état doit
préciser ses projets pour réduire les
amis de les émissions polluantes il y a
un objectif commun aller vers la
neutralité carbone en 2050 on revient
donc de le dire le dirigeant de la chine
sera absent la chine qui est le
principal pollueur de la planète est-ce
qu'on peut quand même aboutir avec ce
sommet à des résultats concluants on
rappelle aussi que la chine va préciser
doit préciser son programme de sorties
du charbon elle devrait se faire cette
sortie en plusieurs décennies
il ya plusieurs éléments il faut savoir
qu'avec nos pas la crise pétrolière dix
ans les mouvements boursiers sur le
cours du pétrole actuellement le charbon
redevient plus ou moins compétitifs donc
vous avez les pays qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix que d' exploiter je pense à la
chine d'exploiter leur charbon va
simplement pour avoir des revenus mais
oui bien évidemment il faut aller vers
une transition écologique en douceur il
faut pas accessoire un coup de massue on
le voit ici et là parfois en france
envers les gens qui subissent des
diffusions trop rapide oui il faut aller
vers cette transition écologique de
façon concertée et de façon raisonnée et
la chine dans ce domaine a fait un
effort incroyable qui a autant ces pays
qui étaient en voie de développement
extrêmement pauvres plus pauvres que
l'afrique il ya 50 ans aujourd'hui est
une grande nation moderne et elle s'est
engagée et on le voit sur place à faire
effectivement un environnement à la fois
le propre je dirais en co2 mais
également humain pour le bien la
question du dir et de l'environnement du
respect de la nature et donc la lutte
contre le carbone est vraiment une des
grandes priorités de la chine jeudi perd
sa vie qu'elle va y arriver très bientôt
cette période malgré tout de crise
énergétique et période aussi
post-pandémie un bon nom d'état cherche
à relancer leur économie est ce que la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
est vraiment la priorité tous sont
plutôt comment est ce que les états
reste il a consigné ses différents axes
jeu que je crois pas que je crois pas
qu'on puisse séparés l'un de l'autre car
l'avenir de la planète de l'homme de la
femme la lyre de nous tous 1,2 des
animaux qui qui qui sont avec nous la
vie de la terre est liée à notre
économie elle élit effectivement à
l'écologie elle est liée à nos
ressources donc c'est également à nous
je dirais de de faire en sorte que nos
ressources telles qu'on les utilise
produisent moins de déchets qu'elles
soient beaucoup plus productive qu'elle
soit beaucoup plus silencieuse beaucoup
plus confortable pour la planète et et
nous-mêmes dont l'économie grâce à
l'innovation grâce aux nouvelles
technologies nous pouvons effectivement
liés ils ces différentes c'est différent
challenge à savoir continuer à voir une
croissance
plutôt verte et puis aussi faire en
sorte de réduire les effets les effets
lutte contre le contre le gaz un dernier
mot à pierre picard concernant les
relations de la france et de la chine
comment se positionne paraît dans cette
rivalité qui oppose washington
et pékin on évoque aussi l'occasion
à l'occasion de ce g20 on évoque la
possibilité pour la france de nouer de
nouveaux partenariats
commerciaux c'est aussi ce sera aussi
l'un des objectifs de ce week-end oui
vous savez la diplomatie rassure à la
diplomatie et lorsque monsieur
byden a succédé à son prédécesseur il
était obligé de garder un petit peu la
ligne turc avait son prédécesseur vous
savez ce sont des administrations et
aussi on ne peut pas les gens n'y
comprendraient rien de changé de
politique radicalement du jour au
lendemain on l'a vu notamment pour la
politique américaine en afghanistan
outre d'autres sujets donc on a bien vu
que le discours d'une équipe hayden a
évolué à changer parce que il fallait
aussi amener l'opinion publique
américaine va occidental qu'on avait
remonté contre la chine
bel et bien mais il fallait le temps
effectivement pour ramener donc une
parole plus sage et c'est ce qu'a fait
le président américain qui est un homme
très très intelligente et très habile
dans ce domaine alors effectivement se
fit dit il y à une concurrence mais la
concurrence est une chose saine il faut
simplement que la concurrence qui vais
et les partenariats partenariat entre
les chinois les américains les chinois
les européens les chinois les français
puisque je suis français il faut qu'il
soit également des opérations qui soit
favorable pour nous tous et qui nous
permettent d'aller de l'avant dans
l'économie et puis dans l'environnement
et surtout n'oublions pas pour le peuple
et le g20 s'ouvre donc demain à rome on
suivra évidemment on cela avec un
attention sur arte france merci beaucoup
pour votre regard pierre picard je
rappelle que vous êtes géopolitologue
spécialiste de l'asie